Hey guys, how's it going? So today we are going to be unboxing a Mavic tray and you might be wondering do I need this?
Probably not but it's really cool. We went to hawaii, there was places. Which you couldn't fly because it's like national parks this that
Whatever reason, and it would be so cool
I thought to have a little monitor to be able to see what I'm doing well, guess what they've got this thing
you've got a little place you can put your Mavic it's got little handles and
Even a little mount to put your iphone on so let's open this up and take a peek. Phone mount up to
iPhone 7 plus so that's good
Let's cut this tiny piece of tape with this excessively large knife.
Here's a little mount and it can adjust sizes for your phone
I mean, this is super simple
But it's pretty cool of course you don't need to get this if you wanna use the sort of as a Steadicam
But this allows you to do a lot more, mount your phones are able to see what you're shooting. Whoo I'm excited about this
So something a lot of people don't even realize is that you can put your magic pro into Wi-Fi mode
And you don't need to use a controller, so the wi-Fi it can be enabled right here. There's a little switch
You just scoot that over to Wi-Fi
Screw this in just like so... It's got a little cushion here this little plastic area
You can just smash this thing
Right onto your Mavic and get a nice tight fit
This looks like one of those little things that you can take in the water they're called...
SeaBobs?. Yes! Okay. Wi-Fi is on
:O This cool. This is actually really cool
Here we go
Do not mind my messy house
There is my cute doggy
Look look look! You want the ball?
Go get your ball Matty c'mon!
Lets go, lets go lets go!
Here ya go, look!
You want this?
Go get your ball
I mean its pretty steady, go figure
What are you doing?
Looks like I'd be great for you
I'm in too it
okay, so I tested this outside the one thing that I will probably have to adjust as I play with it more is the
Autofocus because I actually didn't have the autofocus on so. So one of the things with this is you do have to press where you want
Things to focus sometimes it does go
out of focus. I'm actually quite surprised. I think this is pretty cool
I don't think it's gonna be something that I would use every day
But I love knowing that this is an option because there are those times that I'll have my drone
And I'm not able to actually fly it so at least I'll be able to get some super cool steady shots without having to get
Any type of a steadicam or Ronin or anything
I mean, this is just a super small little solution
And I think will work for you buy one now is make sure you know your wi-Fi password before you get this thing all
Geared up well. Thank you guys so much for watching. I hope you guys enjoyed. This this is pretty cool
I'm super into it and I definitely
Plan on using this in the future. This is made by Polar Pro
It's called to Katana Mavic tray they also make nD filters
And I have some cinematic and my phantom 4 Advanced so I'm going to try those out
And I will give you guys the full review on those in the future so stay tuned. I will see you soon. Bye
Matty, come here look!
Uninterested.